okay so now we come to the business end
of this line and the main move here is
knight catches d7
and after that
most of you are expecting bishop
captures d7 but here comes the surprise
guys we are going to capture with the
queen
and it has a valid point
[Music]
now
as you can see i have highlighted by the
arrows there are three major options
from the wide
and amongst them if you look at the
database here
bishop to c4 is by far
the most popular choice
and against this now we are going to
reveal
why we have taken back with the queen
as black has this lethal reply in this
position
namely b5
well if white bishop has come this far
then he has to go to b3
as bishop to e2 is just a loss of tempo
so bishop to b3 what else
keeping that lovely diagonal
but
exactly here the fun begins with c5
and no matter however white plays i
think black already get upper hand at
just
seventh move of the game
now would you believe
even in feed a games white has played
the move either castle and bishop to e3
and in both the case you know the
consequences
yup
c4 trapping down this white bishop
so that is right out of the equation
if your opponent continue with moves
such as c3
then the answer is very simple you
exchange on d4
and no matter how wave or white plays
let's say queen takes we exchange queen
and at the end white get the iqp a
horrible weakness in the end game and
anybody who knows end game very well
can definitely assure that this is a
slight advantage position to the black
cat
so that leads to the third option and
that is
what about capturing the spawn
and against this black response is very
obvious
queen exchange misplacing the white king
and then regaining the pawn back
which not only attacks the f2
but overall black pieces streaming out
in this line
for example one of my recent game my
2100 rated opponent continue with
rook to evan
counter attacking my pawn
i simply give this check
and my opponent was delighted to play f3
as the e pawn is pin
but
what has been missed out is
black has this nice cunning move
castle on the queen side
not only checking the queen but
unpinning the pawn
so that
after bishop to d2 and pawn captures f3
it doesn't matter how wave worldwide
plays
he get a completely lost position
for example in the game he tried the
move h3
well i took on g2
and after pawn takes g4
this lovely
g1 equals queen force y to give up the
exchange and definitely with the careful
play
it is black who is playing for the full
point
the second move i want to consider is
knight to c3 attacking the e4
well we are going to pin this knot
and please note there is no bishop d2
available here as the d4 pawn drops
so by far the most popular choice is
bishop to c4
trying to castle on the king side
well
black does the same knight to f6
and after a white castle
here comes another tricky moment
where by force we get a completely upper
hand
with this following transaction
bishop takes c3
pawn takes c3 and now
you got the point the reason why we play
queen to d7 as after our queen to c6
suddenly black is attacking two sports
and trust me it is not easy to defend
for the white
for example there is a high profile game
in the database where white continued
with queen to e2
defending the bishop
black castle on the king side
and white naturally enough continue with
bishop to g5
so that he can deflect the black queen
but here comes the winning blow
bishop to g4
and please note queen cannot move as the
bishop on c4 hangs
so sadly enough white has to play f3
but they simply allow to weaken the
white king
and on top of everything
after the move bishop to f5
white has to yet again be very careful
as rook to e8 coming off and that will
dislodge the queen from the special
well in the game black tried bishop
takes f6 but after simple queen takes f6
the net result is
yes the material is balanced but look at
the white position
he has some horrible double pawn on the
queen side where his king is wide open
and indeed at the end black managed to
exploit these factors
and win the game
last but not least the third critical
response
white can play over here is c4
and against this there are two ways you
can maneuver the knight to the f5 square
well in the game black tried knight to
f6 and then launch on f5
however if you do not like this model
then definitely the other route is you
can try knight to e7 and then f5 which
more or less goes to the same direction
okay knight to f6
white plays knight to c3
and after knight to f5
you can see the danger
the d4 pawn is hanging
and accordingly white has three
responses
number one
if they continue with knight to e4
then the simplest is you take on d4
and after the queen exchange
there is a threat on c2 so white should
play bishop to d3
whereupon bishop to f5
gives black a fast development of pcs
with some ongoing attack
there is a game in the leeches which
goes as follow
white continued with bishop to d2
black indeed castle on the queen side
and after white castle on the quin side
he get root shock with knight to b3
check
which not only misplaced the white pawn
structure
but the end result after rook captures
d3
black obviously stands better
so it is pretty clear that knight
captures e4 gives black a completely
easy game
so how about the second option
bishop to e3
well this time around we have easy
response
you play the move c5
attacking on d4 and after the natural
response d5
what else but taking down this important
bishop
so that
after moves like f5
white has a clear weakness on e3 and
with the bishop pair
black obviously stands quite well
so that leads to our last option
how about d pha here
getting rid of all these attacking ideas
by black
well against this i am recommending you
play bishop to p4
pin down this knight
and after bishop to d2
you simply continue with queen to e7
looking for the juicy break e3
in general terms white can't stop it
because
if required black can castle and put the
rook on e file and then play e3 so more
or less white should deal with it
well let's finish up this chapter on a
high note with a grand master game where
white continue with bishop to e2
and after both the side castle
black indeed goes for e3
so that after pawn takes e3
knight takes e3
bishop takes e3 and queen takes e3
it doesn't matter whatever white plays
not only black get bishop pair
and in the game grand master continue
with bishop to d7 and convert the full
point
however my recommendation is you simply
take on c3 and gobble up an extra pawn
and with some careful play black can
look forward confidently in upcoming
middle game with a clear pawn advantage
that's it guys i hope
now you are confident enough to meet all
these sidelines of the elephant gambit
well as i have shown in this video
there is a reason these are called the
sidelines and black has to fear
absolutely nothing
and meet this lines with confidently
well thank you for watching this video
and i wish you best of luck
for trying this tricky elephant gambit
in
your tournament practice
bye and take care